scp 682 versus scp-093  our dimension can't seem to keep the  hard-to-destroy reptile down but maybe  the dimension that scp-093 the red sea  object offers us access to across the  mirror plane might have better luck the  object passed around scp-682 until it  turned green and affixed itself to a  nearby mirror purposefully selected to  be big enough to allow scp-682 through  when it refused to enter the mirror was  brought over 682 was pushed in and then  the mirror was shattered however later  on the mirror anomalously put itself  back together and scp-682 was pushed  back out because of course he was  scp-682 commented of his time on the  other side i am not very amused